-I'm about to perform
some kid theater,
but first I need
an acting partner.
And I couldn't ask for
a better one.
She's a legendary pop icon
and music superstar!
Please welcome the one,
the only, Madame X!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you kidding?
I bow. I bow!
I bow down to the queen.
-Jimmy, stand up.
-I love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
That's exactly right!
Alright.
Welcome.
Welcome to the show, Madame X.
Thank you for doing this.
-Thank you for having me.
-You have a new movie
out tomorrow
on Paramount+ called "Madame X."
And I thought it would be fun
to preview some scenes
for our audience by acting them
out together.
But here's the catch.
The scenes we'll be reading are
not from the actual film.
Instead they are written by
elementary school kids.
-Which is why I'm wearing
an elementary school dress.
-Yes, of course. I know, I know.
Of course. I got it. I got it.
I totally got it.
We gave the kids no direction.
We just said --
"Madame X" is all we told them
and let them do the rest.
So it's time for "Kid Theater."
Here we go.
♪ -Kid theater, kid theater ♪
-This first one is from Jess.
She's seven years old.
Madame X, you'll be playing
the role of Madame X.
I'll be playing
the role of Denny.
Higgins will read
the scene descriptions.
Higgins, set up the scene,
please.
-Denny and Madame X
are at the ice cream place.
-When it's your birthday,
you get free ice cream.
-It's my birthday.
-The ice cream waiter throws
Madame X free ice cream,
and she catches it with one
hand then with two hands.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I have some of
your ice cream?
-Oh.
-Sorry.
-Oh [bleep]
-Wait, no.
[ Laughter ]
That's not in the script.
[ Cymbal crashes ]
That's not in the script at all.
-I know, but I'm holding
two ice cream cones.
[ Laughter ]
Well, maybe I'll give you some
ice cream if you dance for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Denny does a slow dance.
-Come on, baby.
-It is very, very slow.
[ Laughter ]
-Hurry up. It's melting.
[ Slow music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This dance you're doing
right now, it's too slow.
-Mm-hmm.
-Can you dance faster?
And more normal
and use your hands
and your shoulders
and your chin.
-Chin?
-Chin.
[ Music quickens ]
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
-Denny pretends to be normal
and dances using his hands,
his shoulders, and his chin.
-That's a normal dance.
What are you thinking about
while you're doing
a normal dance?
[ Laughter ]
-Normal stuff.
Pants, bread, numbers, you know.
I don't have to tell you.
-Yes, you do.
Don't talk back to me.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not in
the script at all!
-Yes, it --
[ Laughs ]
But I think that you do have to
tell me because I'm not normal.
[ Laughter ]
That's in the script.
-Yeah, it is actually, yeah.
How can we tell?
-By my dance.
-Madame X does a dance
that's not normal,
and she's eating
her free ice cream.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright. Alright. Alright.
Hold on. Hold on now.
Alright, alright, alright,
hold on now.
Alright, very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Alright, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not done with my dance.
You're censoring me.
-No, I'm not. Never.
I would never.
♪♪
Alright, alright, okay, okay.
Alright, Higgins,
whose line is it?
Whose line is it? Okay.
No, no, no!
-It's your line.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Madame Triple X.
-Alright, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-It's melted.
Here, lick my hand.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And scene.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. That was great.
Alright. Here we go.
Let's do this.
Alright, that's one.
Alright, let's go.
Now let's do another one.
This was sent by Theodore.
This stars two characters,
Madame X and Stupid Fox.
[ Laughter ]
Do I play Ma--
Okay, here we go.
Higgins, set it up.
-This is the story of Madame X
and her Stupid Fox.
[ Laughter ]
Madame X looks out
over the castle,
waiting for the Stupid Fox.
♪ -I am Madame X ♪
♪ My castle is a wreck ♪
-Come on.
♪ -It was so destroyed by
this old Stupid Fox ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I will put him in a timeout ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks for the vocal support.
-Greetings, Madame X.
It is I, your trusty friend,
Stupid Fox.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very mad at you,
Stupid Fox.
You left all your stupid toys
all over my beautiful castle.
-I did not.
-Yes, you did. Shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-I did not.
-Shut up.
-Shut up. You did.
Shut up.
-Let us not -- let us not argue.
-I agree.
Arguing is not fun.
I want to have fun, Stupid Fox.
[ Laughter ]
Fun, I say.
-Yeah.
♪ I will put my toys away ♪
♪ I'm sorry I made a mess ♪
♪ I'm just a Stupid Fox ♪
♪ I'm sorry, Madame X ♪
-That's kind of good.
-Not bad?
-That's not bad, actually.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's kind of -- Yeah.
That song was beautiful,
Stupid Fox.
So beautiful that I'm going to
change your name.
-Is my name now Beautiful Fox?
-No.
It's Less Stupid Fox.
-Alright.
There we go, and scene.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you to Madame X.
Stick around.
We're talking to Madonna --
I mean Madame X --
after the break!
Come on back!